just wonderful to have reunion here
tonight and be celebrating Lynn
Tillman's wonderful wonderful book and
I'd like to thank Niklas Rojas and
Gloria Troy for all they've done for the
programs that I've done here and for
organizing this wonderful program and
now it's such a pleasure for me to
introduce Lynn Tillman who walked into
my life three years ago when I was
planning this book which I thought was
going to celebrate our 20th anniversary
instead it turned out to be the whole
closing of the bookstore in a kind of
history of what had gone on in
literature and in publishing over the
last 20 years so she just did an
incredible job and through it she's
become one of my dearest and closest
friends and she's a wonderful wonderful
writer her new book in paperback no
lease in life was nominated for the
National Book Critics Circle Award and
so that is available her other novels
are cast in doubt motion sickness and
haunted houses and she has two
collections of short fiction the Madame
realism complex and absent makes the
heart the broad picture and the velvet
years Warhol's Factory and other books
and she's co-director of the writing
Department of Bard College she was a
visiting professor at Brown University
and a visiting critic for the critical
issue seminar in Yale University's
Graduate sculpture department then is
very very distinguished that we'd like
to welcome Lindemann
thank you thank you very much it's very
exciting to see all of you out here are
so many friends and so many of the
people who were in the book and I'm just
thrilled I want to introduce to you a
really extraordinary writer and wit Fran
Lebowitz she honors the book by being in
it she has she contributed such
wonderful ideas and thoughts about the
city and about bookstores and about
everything and I've also gotten to know
her a little bit during this the past
few years and it's really a privilege
and an honor to introduce her to you
Fran Lebowitz
hello first I would like to say either
the rest of you are disgracefully
underdressed or as soon as I'm finished
I'll bring you the wine list
hmm Lin is great and shorter than me um
I I was told in fact commanded by both
Jeanette and Lin that what I should read
to you tonight was a were things that I
said that are in the book and I thought
this was a B chord because um I believe
that life is fair I thought everybody
was told this so apparently everyone
else got to choose I would not have
chosen to read my own my own
conversation to you for for numerous
reasons but chief among them well it
would be a good lesson for all those of
you who think that writing and talking
are the same thing and also because I
didn't get to edit this I'll try to edit
a little as I go along
but I'm not fair this is a this a little
bit of rambling conversation is about
Burt Britton who was originally
Jeanette's partner but before he was
Jeanette's partner at the bookstore
he ran the review so he ran a number of
things that they had strand bookstore
and I'd known him since I was a teenager
actually um so this is a me talking
it's very contemporary isn't it
I had number for many years by the time
books and company started the second I
started writing for little magazines and
I cannot stress the word little enough I
would get books in the mail you can tell
that no one really wants books you can
tell how highly value they are by the
fact that a 19 year old kid writing for
a magazine with a circulation of 6 gets
inundated with hundreds of review copies
the books you didn't want you would
bring to the Strand which paid a quarter
I think of the retail price so basically
this accounted for at various times
between a quarter and a third of my
income I remember once getting 70
dollars in cash my rent was one hundred
and twenty one dollars and seventy eight
cents so that was a very substantial sum
of money
I always felt Burke gave you more than
you were supposed to get he would take
the books and it was like watching a
card shark shuffle a deck of cards it
was the only experience I have ever had
in my life where I got more than I
thought I was going to get when Paula
story said it'll sound better there's
there won't be much left slim Biggins
for mr. Oscar um remember fourth Avenue
when they had all the secondhand
bookstores you had to beg those guys to
sell you a book you had a screamin
yellow to get their attention because
they were always reading remember those
horrible old grumpy guys you would say
how much is this they would grumble I
don't know put a figure on it could you
give me some idea of how much so
booksellers always agreed not to make a
lot of money but they didn't agree to
was what has happened since chains came
in no one can agree to that because
that's not just agreeing not to make a
lot of money that's agreeing to starve
to death and it's very hard to get
people's consensus on that scene
um you're having to guess the questions
by the way because Lynn took them out I
would be in favor of the chains if they
stay out of cities they are anti urban
there are many places in this country
that have no bookstore because there are
no places left in the country there are
just malls so then you have a chain in a
mall and that makes sense it's better
than not having any bookstore but in the
city you don't want this because the
point of a city to me is why did we move
here did we move here because there
weren't enough chain stores where we
came from we came from there that's why
we came here we didn't come here because
we had a burning desire to pay eight
thousand dollars a month rent we came
here to get away from that now that is
here now there's no place to go the
things that make a city are the opposite
things that are exemplified by these
chains my anger at the chains is that
they came here bookstores coffee stores
whatever we want all the little junkie
we're places that's why we came here
it's like the smoking laws what did New
York have why do tourists come here
now New York is full of tourists it's
all Giuliani ever talks about he's
turned New York into a tourist
attraction that means it's over there's
nothing to see they come to see the
remnants they come to see the ruins like
ancient Greece there's nothing here
anymore
this isn't anymore place to make books
it is a place to sell them it is not a
place to make paintings it is a place to
sell them always right as an artist sit
around and drink and pop and smoke
cigarettes now they make a place where
you can't do that
this is not supposed to be a health spa
no one ever moved here for their health
you want to be in a healthy environment
think of anywhere else why do they have
to turn New York City into a suburb when
there are already plenty of them why the
city had to be made comfortable for the
middle-class American white tourists I
have no idea there is never a
consideration of the native population
we are the indigenous population of the
city we deserve to be here they do not
they knock down Times Square so where
did our hookers have to go where are our
hookers where are our three-card Monte
dealers Joanna says all this is bringing
in business like the Virgin Records
store he's not even an American all this
money all this Hardware ihcafe stop all
these theme restaurants they don't live
here the money goes right out of the
city that isn't money put back into the
city except in the form of taxes and if
they weren't here there would be other
stores here our stores were here
Bergdorf's Tiffany's that's what belongs
uptown does came or Kmart belong here no
it does not we had a very nice
Woolworths
writers and readers get attached to
their bookstore then they take it away
but that's what constitute a city the
places you go the idea behind the chains
is let's make a bookstore for people who
don't feel comfortable in bookstores who
are intimidated by bookstores
let's make a city for people who are
intimidated by bookstores I'm not
running for anything I don't have to say
I trust the people I do not stay home do
we go there I don't see what the pair I
don't know what the paradigm is of a
store that America it feels comfortable
in a supermarket I guess we don't have
supermarkets in New York we still don't
I would like to be the mayor of New York
for one term I would make this place so
uncomfortable for tourists you have no
idea
I would give New York back to the New
Yorkers but I know one thing I'm not
popular enough to be the mayor it does
occasionally bring a chill to my heart
that there are more people who like
Giuliani than like me it's also pretty
scary to think that there are more
people who like Jesse Helms than like me
of course this was before last week so I
now I suppose because these remarks I be
can be classified as a premature
anti-fascist so this is apparently in
response to something Lynn or Jeanette
said about the panels that they had a
books on companies and this is in regard
to a screenwriting panel which I was not
on the most unhappy people I ever from
that are screenwriters if what you're
interested in is movies then it's fine
to be a screenwriter but if what you're
interested in is writing it's absurd to
be a screenwriter it is not a writer's
medium you have no control and as I
always say why do you think they give
you all that money I remember being on a
panel of books and company because I
haven't very frequently been on panels
maybe two dozen times in my life I
remember all them to some extent because
I dislike being on panels I don't like
other people being allowed to talk
a panel always means that I'm going to
be with about six people who don't agree
with me
I suppose in an audience of two thousand
people they can't they won't agree with
you but they're not allowed to talk I
expect people to disagree with me but I
do not expect them to be allowed to talk
that is why I don't like being on panels
thank you
she's just amazing people have asked me
how I did this book so I thought I would
and in fact one of the responses to this
book is Lin how did you do it so I
thought I would read a couple of
paragraphs from the introductory essay
because often introductory essays are
not read and might explain to you a
little bit about how I how I did this
when I began researching book books and
company's history I discovered how
inextricably it was part of Jeannette
Watson's life I'd never met Jeanette
before I was not a native informant I'd
never read at the store I'd bought books
there from time to time attended some
readings it represented my books but it
wasn't my bookstore I knew almost
nothing about its history though I was a
writer I also knew very little about how
a bookstore worked my job I told myself
was in part to make that understandable
how a bookstore operates how books get
chosen and why how a philosophy animates
each independent bookstore I also wanted
to look at the roles of editors
publicists sales reps and publishers who
figuratively deliver books to bookstores
Jeanette Watson once told me her store
was a nineteenth-century idea she told
me she wanted her love of books to be to
be communicated in an ideal place for
them writers sometimes invoke the ideal
reader publishers the general reader
muses for each group these ideal types
are inventions probably necessary
allusions and just as authors in a way
create their readers with each new book
traditionally independent bookstores
create their customers no two
independent bookstores are exactly alike
in selection of books or ambience I'll
jump writing this book was a combination
of doing history cultural history and
biography I hadn't expected it to be
biography once I started working with
the material I realized I needed to jail
to tell Jeanette's story the impulse to
start Books & Company was hers and her
desire and
it gave birth to the store and kept it
going writing her biography from the
interviews was like being a portraitist
Jeannette was in a way my material my
primary source material if she was
sitting for me sitting in front of me
then I was using many of her words her
expressions to draw from and paint with
interpreting them and augmenting them to
make a continuous fairly chronological
narrative in a sense I turned
information into narration the
interviews of course did not go from A
to B I asked many questions and we
talked about many things sometimes in no
specific order from the interviews
letters and her Diaries I had to
establish links between events make
inferences and segues and forge
conclusions that seemed appropriate
using Jeanette's actual words when
possible I decided to keep her voice in
the first person like the other
contributors to maintain the books
immediacy and directness I had to think
as if I were Jeanette and recall events
in her life as if they were mine It was
as if I were writing her autobiography
it was a strange experience something
out of mind invaders and as much as I
appreciated the dedication of
biographers before I respect them even
more now more conventionally I did oral
history - organizing the other
interviewees material selecting and
editing commentaries to interrupt
Jeanette's story these interventions
would amplify or diverge from the tale
she was telling and there was an
enormous number of possibilities the
range of topics and expression was
gloriously broad beautifully articulated
and the reader of bookstore will find a
fuller discussion of some of the issues
I've touched upon earlier in this essay
and much more but Jeanette's voice kept
the narrative going she was the engine
others could stroll down memory lane and
bring into it other memories and themes
I wanted to include as much as I could
this book's design was to showcase along
with Gillette Jeanette's life and her
stores many other lives and ideas the
way good bookstores do people go to
bookstores for many reasons people read
for many reasons we enter these stores
with expectation
perhaps we readers want to find
ourselves in everything we
but if it's in a book and much is
booksellers try to fulfill the readers
demand it's not an easy job just as
writing books or publishing them is not
a bookstore is not only a cultural space
but also a social space and a place for
fantasy and desire it is a business
place to subject to the market to
changing business practices and consumer
tastes and all of this is in the story
of Books & Company to me the store
became a living entity a house full of
voices many of which are presented in
bookstore I hope that bookstore will
live as a kind of book of books a book
for people who love them and who care
about the fascinating business of
bringing them into our world thank you
and now here's Jeannette
well I thought I would read some of
brandon gills because he helped me so
much
start the bookstore and he's so much a
part of the Municipal Arts Society and
the landmarks Conservancy and I wish
that he could be here tonight to
celebrate the book so here's his
description of me says in that family
Jeanette was the bookish one curled up
with books while the others were more
physical out in the world more like her
wonderful father Thomas he was one of
the most charismatic extraordinary
people I ever met
he was so charismatic to the point rate
if he told you something was so it was
not only so but you would back it with
your own life for example once he
invited me to fly up to stove for a
skiing weekend we were to meet in
Westchester and fly up a blizzard came
and the airport was closed actually one
of Jack Kennedy's close friends was also
supposed to be going up with his
girlfriend and when they saw the storm
and the airport closed they begged off
but Tom said I'm going out do you want
to come Brendan I said of course I'll
come because it was Tom Watson it was a
plane he had not flown off and before
and he was going to fly himself he had a
co-pilot but he had a book of
instructions spread on his legs and then
he said into the microphone I'm taking
responsibility for this flight and I'm
getting out of here they put the lights
on and we went off in the snow when we
got up in the air turned out the airport
in Stowe was also closed and Tom had
gotten in touch with somebody and they
opened up another Airport newly plowed
just for us and Tom this was the common
place another time he had to get back to
New York City and Tom said I have a
helicopter that has something the matter
with it and I'm flying it to Boston and
you can catch a regular commercial
flight again no hesitancy on my part
here's a helicopter which I hate and
there's something the matter with it and
we're going to take off it was summer
and Tom had his shorts rolled up and on
the way off the island down to Boston he
was making notations on his bare skin
his upper thigh
and I thought Here I am thousands of
feet in the air
with a man who has had a massive heart
attack and just recovered from it and
there are certain extraordinary
notations on his upper leg and if he had
another heart attack
what do I do how do I read the upper leg
of a dead man
I knew Tom would get me to Boston there
wasn't a chance in the world we wouldn't
get to Boston that's the way he was and
then I have one other selection
Susan Scott was at books and company for
eight years and she worked with Peter
and she became a floor manager and she
described what happened at a reading
with Bernard Malamud when Bernard
Malamud was reading we began hearing
extremely strange and inexplicable
noises Andrew had been adjusting the
microphone and all the sound equipment
and the sound equipment was just held
together with band-aids it barely
functioned there was only one person
usually who knew how to paste it
together so it would work Andrew thought
he had it all set then we started
hearing a bizarre noise a noise never
heard before
when Andrew didn't know how to deal with
I looked up in Malamud and said my god
it's his pacemaker Andrew had to run
upstairs and take the mic away from his
chest move it free move it further up
toward his face so it wouldn't pick up
the noise thank you and now it's my
great pleasure to introduce Peter
Philbrook who is the manager at books
and company for 15 years and was just a
famous buyer when no one had ever heard
of perfume by Patrick Susskind he
ordered 700 copies of it and I was
terrified that we wouldn't be able to
sell them but we sold every single one
he also ordered a great many of the name
of the rose whose brilliant brilliant
buyer and now Peter is at Barnes and
Noble and he runs an out-of-print
website so you can go there to find
wonderful out of print books and you
should be very happy to learn that he's
starting
academic website so all of those great
philosophy books and things that you
could find in books and company now you
can go to Peter and find at Barnes &
Noble so let's welcome Peter Phil Brooke
all right welcome to books and company
I'm saying that now because I always
hated saying it before I thought about
going to read tonight I came up with
nothing so I'm going to tell a story and
the reason for that is the there's a
place in the book where Jeanette
mentions how painfully shy I was which I
think was an exaggeration he said said I
wouldn't look people in the eye and
something in fact I was alienated it was
it was alienation but that's I was proud
of that at the time but I can't speak in
front of an audience basically that's
the problem
it's kind of a Viennese neurosis you
know Lucille couldn't touch money but so
this is like torture for me to do this
and the most painful part of books and
company so we have to have both sides
was introducing readings and I didn't
really have to do it very often because
I always found a way to get out of it
and that Jeannette was sympathetic but
she also would torture me because she
would she would say well I'm going to be
away no who's going to do the
introduction or if I suggested a reader
then I would have to introduce him and
she would always really zing me because
actually she was terrible when she began
doing introductions but over the years
she got great either she trained herself
do the pebbles in the mouth and all that
kind of stuff anyway and one of the
actually one of the worst introductions
I ever did was for Paul Auster remember
probably no one remembers this but it
was for city of glass and I was really
really did a lot to prepare this and I
got a couple anecdotes ready of our
friendship and how we met moves it was
it was beautiful
but I began the introduction and I
forgot half of the anecdote one anecdote
but everybody just let that go but I
went on and I remember the second one I
forgot half of that too and everyone was
just kind of like looking around I think
you yeah so it's like it's be it was
really like a Beckett story which
probably understand but so I can't go on
I'll go on I think I've said my piece
I've done it thank you for asking me to
speak and thank you
it's now my pleasure to introduce Paul
Auster Paul has been a longtime was a
longtime customer of books and company
and he also read there many times and
had a book party there and or maybe to
book parties there and Janette gave him
the dinner I mean not that he hadn't
been eating but but but they were there
were the days were more skin - anyway
right his latest book is Timbuktu it's a
wonderful book and he's a wonderful
writer and a terrific person and please
welcome Paul Paul Auster
Thank You men unlike friendly boots I
couldn't stand the idea of reading my
own comments so I picked some other
peoples that I think are wonderful the
first one is really a delicious bit of
memory about books by Simon Schama the
historian there's nothing to do with
books and company but it's about books I
was a bit of an embarrassment because I
was reading at 2:00 or something or so
my parents tell me my father I wouldn't
normally believe because he used to brag
irrationally about me but my mother as
in a classic Jewish household would
contradict everything and she agrees
that I was reading very very early I
remember reading comics classics
Illustrated they had a version I seem to
remember of a Bible there would be
Isaiah standing there in his little
pajamas with an enormous bubble coming
out of his mouth with the whole of the
prophecy of Isaiah or Elijah being fed
by the Ravens I thought this was very
cool I remember where I grew up on
leigh-on-sea and Essex there was an old
used bookstore that was full of old
almanacs it had things like the life of
Napoleon but I remember one of the first
things that I saw it was an old
photographic history that was published
in 1936 I think it was for George v for
the 25th anniversary of his coronation
so it was actually a kind of history of
Britain from the death of Queen Victoria
to baby George v the most boring King of
the 20th century it had lots of pictures
in little texts the trench warfare in
the First World War I remember it had
embossed blue covers and it was very
heavy and the photographs were all kind
of sepia brown I was very very
fascinated by this book I would come
back to the book store to look at it and
it was two shillings or something more
than my pocket money but I kept on
coming back and in the end the
bookseller gave it to me he was so tired
I must have been about six or seven it
was very nice I must have been this
rather comical little figure at the time
there was something about the smell of
old books they had a rather putting east
smell
I was very interested in literally the
smell of different papers and books old
books and new books I remember an old
British publisher used this very pulpy
soft kind of doughy paper that was
wonderful you could press your little
thumb into it it would make a little
indentation and others dent for example
had a very shiny slightly strange stock
quite like coated paper somehow the
actual tactile qualities of books
appealed to me foxing when really old
books developed brown spots was very
interesting to me these strange Meisel
like blemishes would appear and when I
first saw my first wormhole that was
incredibly exciting to I was looking on
through wormhole books to see if the
worm was still there or the body of the
worm was wormholes that have really
eaten their way through pages goes
sideways through the book so there's a
pattern from one page to the next I
thought those were amazingly interesting
I was living in the seaside and my other
great passion was to Beach comb and you
could see sea worms and tiny critters
burrowing books seemed to me to have
this kind of oceanic almost primordial
quality
I loved all that as much as I loved the
first pictures very sexual very sensuous
and the next one is from Roy blunts a
very funny man I've had the pleasure of
meeting a few times and he describes
something that went on in the store I
think there was some kind of party for
his book the book of southern humour he
was reading from it which is an
anthology so here's Roy Blount jr. I've
been going around talking about this
book here and there and the first most
common question I find on the book tour
is as you sit down heavily next to
someone and sort of cringe and wait for
the first question the first question is
do you get tired of hearing the same
questions over and over
of course you can't say yes the terrible
thing is because then the program is
just dead if you say yes the second one
lately has been what do you think of
newts I have a lot more to say about
that I've been looking for Republicans
all day today they ought to come up with
a new name for Newt because you name a
boy Newt you get a mean boy so I thought
the Republicans should call him
jubilation T Gingrich or something or if
they changed his name to Isaac Newton
Gingrich they could call him Ike but I
hope they don't think of that it might
work but one of the things about
southern humor is as I've gotten tired
of saying that it derives from a rich
oral tradition there's also a rich nasal
tradition obviously in southern humor
it's a rich oral tradition but it seemed
to me that the only person in the last
election who seemed to be coming from
that rich oral tradition was and
Richards who got beat and the ones who
didn't get beat came from a poor anal
tradition so that's what I've been
saying about politics and I've also been
saying that there are three essential
elements of southern humor one is that
it's very oral it arrives from the
aforesaid rich oral tradition and it
also involves animals quite often and it
also involves food eating so if you
consider an oyster an animal the
following poem by myself brings all
those elements together it goes like
this I like to eat an uncooked oyster
nothing slicker
nothing's moister nothing is easier on
your gorge or when the time comes to
discharge but not to let it too long
rest within your mouth is always best
for if your mind dwells on an oyster
nothing slicker nothing's moister I'd
prefer my oyster fried then I'm sure my
oysters died
that pretty much sums up southern humor
and then the last bit on a completely
different note but I found very touching
and in some way an emblem of what books
and company really was as a bookstore
it's a description by Calvin Trillin of
Joe Mitchell's reading there in I guess
the early 90s and here's Calvin Trillin
speaking Joe Mitchell hadn't published
anything in The New Yorker for about 30
years then up in the old hotel came out
in 1992 then in about 1994 they put out
the bottom of the harbor he was sort of
the hero to a lot of people my age at
the New Yorker and not at the New Yorker
a nonfiction writer it was almost a cult
most people had never heard of him but
he was the best nonfiction writer at
least in my view the New Yorker ever had
he wrote not about grandiose subjects
but the Fulton Street fish market and
the Bowery and various things like that
I never heard of him until just before I
came to the New Yorker somebody gave me
one of his books and it was just
astonishing I don't write the way he
wrote I don't mean that it was
stylistically influential but I think a
lot of writers roughly my contemporaries
saw him as an extraordinary figure then
of course the mystery of his not writing
added to it when the bottom of the
harbor was put out by the Modern Library
Jeannette had a reading for him it was
two or three years after up in the old
hotel came out but still I thought of
him as someone who wasn't well-known
even though I think up in the oh-ho up
in the old hotel might have been on the
bestseller list briefly Alice and I had
promised to be at somebody's house for
dinner that night but we thought we
would stop and pay our respects we
couldn't get in the building there were
people out the door on the street it was
fantastic and a lot of them were young
people I was just astonished I told you
net the next day there was like a rock
star or something like that
we finally edged up the stairs just to
say hello because we had to leave it was
a wonderful event because you knew that
people who went into that store
appreciate
Joe Mitchell didn't have to be somebody
whose name was in the paper in the
gossip columns every day he must have
been I guess a retiring type and then as
a footnote to that story Brendan Gill
continues the story of that reading that
was one of the high moments of Joe
Mitchell's life he'd never done a
reading before I was supposed to
introduce him when I got there at 6:00
or something was absolutely so
jam-packed that there was no way for me
to get upstairs I heard Jeanette
introducing him you couldn't get through
the crowd even on the ground floor and
looking out through the shop window I
saw the street was full of people for
Joe Mitchell he was 87 years of age what
could have been more thrilling for him
and he thought he couldn't read he was
pretty much of a stammerer and very
uneasy speaking any thought oh god every
word coming out was very difficult when
he spoke to even old old friends like me
but in point of fact when he got up to
speak he did an absolutely great job it
was great and he was so happy after that
then just a few weeks later he was dead
he had all kinds of cancer that he
didn't know about Thanks
okay so now Lina and I are going to read
the end of the book which is so touching
that I hope I'm not going to cry while I
read it she just did a great job but I
want to end this book close its door
where books and company's heart was with
the writer reading her work to readers
to an enthusiastic audience our last
reading was on May 15 1997 and our last
reader was the exceptional Edna O'Brien
Edna and John Merrow were longtime
friends and another connection only
connect it was Jean Moreau who first
told Edna O'Brien that she should
patronize books and company so it
happened that our very last reader was a
friend in her own Irish right after Edna
finished her remarkable reading her
voice is like the richest chocolate she
addressed the audience again that's
enough of me thank you very much I would
just like to say one thing that I know
for Jeannette and for all her friends
what an emotional and poignant and
painful evening it must be but the thing
about whatever ends in our lives whether
it be a place or a person they do not
end in the memory and imagination and
spirit of the people and I'm sure this
bookshop will be a legend forever
and I'm so honored to be a part of
what's happening now and bless you all I
return to the podium and get my last
speech at the store it was a singular
moment it was the story swan song but I
was a bookseller to the end I thank the
audience for coming thank dad no for her
reading and gracious remarks and
encouraged everyone to buy a copy of her
book and get it signed
Edna had ended the evening just the way
I liked it on a hopeful note I did hope
that books and company and what it stood
for would live on in people's hearts and
minds and now I encourage you all to buy
the book
you so much for coming